I'll be on my soup and Posse pass [__]
can I eat up you good fangs
I could eat you up the flow the look
[Music]
Oh what is going on you two recently
non-subscriber and your all the 105
found myself and you are really heal
grown up but I've to get it up
what I figured it out is that real are
you serious dude you need to go back to
school get your [__] life together
you know growing up without realized
that a lot of us instead of trying to
find out who we really are we try to
find out what other people want us to be
and I've heard the sorriest excuses
before by yourself thirty-five years old
you've done by yourself you lost it but
I'm gonna chill no right now girl you
signed out that it'll let you know that
you haven't found yourself or you just
aren't being real with yourself at all
[Music]
if you find yourself changing who you
are depending on the people you're
around you probably had a fan yourself
in then must always that one person you
know that changes up who they are
depending on where they're around like
you're on that one my friend that always
does it up whatever a black person walks
by last guy
two shots four beers up top baby did
that was like Utah ain't about tonight
to give me hey in case you didn't know
imma let you in on a secret
you look like a [__] idiot and look I
already know what you're gonna say why
do you talk Jenna [__] [__]
grew up in a predominantly black area
Grasso leaves my whole life if anything
like a sister with a weave complex but
all the sassy black women twelve sixteen
years old and he'll laugh in a fight so
beat you for the program know somebody
hold my purse you know you ever found
yourself if you're still being peer
pressured into drinking look if Peter
pressure still affects you twenty years
after puberty you a little [__] in case
you haven't noticed if you don't want a
drink you don't have to oh I hate it
when people tell me to drink something
but they won't tell me what decided and
it always got some crazy ass [__]
name hey bro don't ask what's in it but
it's called
what why cuz you'll wake up with a dick
in your mouth
duh because I'm kids that's a quick way
to find yourself butt naked with a
cucumber at the [__] Piko offer me a
drink
that's nothing to do with a dick in my
mouth I don't get down like that it's
America she have to drink something to
blow my bracelet so at the same time
[__] idiot you know the only time I
think I had a drink when I was drinking
with a bunch of thugs because in all
honesty at that point I'll be scared for
my life got two options young good drink
or drink action that's only one option
you just hit it twice
[__] put in your mouth woo
if you're still doing things just to
please others then you really haven't
found yourself don't be that guy that
agrees with what everybody else says
just because you want them to like you
[__] that they don't like you they just
like the fact that you make them feel
better because you agree with them on
everything personally I hate it when
somebody makes a bad joke and then they
make eye contact with you like you
supposed to that just awkward as that
then Rick said let's stop my paper clip
you can go around your whole life trying
to please everybody else but what are
you with it by the time to go ahead and
please yourself
wait that's nothing the only time you
should ever bring in that fake laugh is
when you looking for a job
oh you're talking to a cop excuse me do
you realize how fast you were going
apparently too fast stop laughing and
all I see if you want to find out who
you are and get to know you you got to
go out there and experience life don't
be afraid to go out there and try new
things and [__] up because honestly you
learn from your mistakes and you become
a better person problem you gotta get
out there push your boundaries and
stimulate yourself I mean that sound - I
don't the more you push yourself and
test your boundaries you become that
much more closer to realizing your full
potential and who you really are to be
honest with you I messed up a lot when I
was a kid and look where I'm at single
big breasted talk to myself in the room
to a camera for the rest of my life I'm
so happy
like the legend either fina ill is ill
and you just not being really was really
with yourself really with yourself fun
that's a rap song here we go
it's not a [__] police aren't I hit
live in LA everybody in Robin [__]
[__] this you know growing up a lot you
know growing up what I found out what
hey you know if you would stop getting
butt